JASON: You guys are obviously
playing Detroit tonight,
the great city of Detroit.
So thank you for spending
some time with us.
I guess since we're on
the topic of the tour,
maybe we can throw out a
question about the tour.
I guess Joey, I'm
looking at you.
So maybe we'll start at that end
and kind of work our way down.
So you maybe tell us about
what's going on with the tour?
You guys have been on
the road for, I think,
a little over a year now,
touring to promote your latest
album that came out last
year, "Head Carrier," which
is fantastic.
What's the tour been like?
And maybe just to take
that a step further,
how has touring changed?
What's this tour like
compared to tours
you guys were doing
in the '80s and '90s,
besides Paz being here,
and then also tours
that you did in 2004, 2009?
What's the dynamic like now?
JOEY: Good question.
[LAUGHTER]
Well, the tour's
been going well.
Everyone's laughing,
doing their own things.
We get together back in the bus
and go, what did you do today?
And what did you do?
And then we talk
about what we did.
[LAUGHTER]
And then the difference
between now and then
was, well, we'd be
in the bus and we'd
wonder where we were and
we'd have to look at the map
and then look at
the signs and then
figure out where we were, are.
We'd have to wake up to do that.
So now we're in our bunk
and we just go on our phone
and then go back to sleep.
That's the big difference.
JASON: And I'm assuming you
use Google to figure that out.
Is that right?
CHARLES: I don't
even know what it is.
[LAUGHTER]
I just ask it.
We just ask it.
I just ask it where we
are and it tells me.
I guess it's Google.
JASON: It's like magic, right?
CHARLES: Is it Google?
JOEY: It's Google.
JASON: OK, good.
JOEY: It's on default.
JASON: That's perfect.
Good.
That's the proper
answer, thank you.
Fantastic.
Quick show of hands
with the crowd.
Has anyone here been to
a Pixies show before?
That's great.
It's not enough.
We'll get a few more of you
there this evening, hopefully.
For those of you who haven't
been to a Pixies show,
it's a fantastic experience.
One of my favorite
parts of a Pixies show
is that there's no set list.
And what I mean by that is
that the band kind of chooses
on a whim what's being played
next, usually led by Charles,
I believe.
So Charles, maybe tell us a
little bit about that dynamic
and how you kind of read or
feel the audience or the band's
energy and decide, hey,
this is the next song
that I'm going to
throw out to the band
and we're going to rock it out.
CHARLES: I don't know.
I suppose it's just
different all the time.
I'm having random
thought processes.
Like oh, that was a song that
mentioned a caribou in it.
I know, snake.
Caribou, snake, animals.
And I'll go on like some animal.
I'll be like, I've got four
animal songs I just did.
And then monkey, monkey.
And then sometimes
it'll be like,
oh yeah, that's a good set-up,
because that song sounds
like it's talking
about this next song.
And it will be some
sort of abstract kind
of a thought like that.
Or it might be like, oh gee,
they're really not reacting
to these new songs at all.
We'd better, come on,
let's do the "Here
Comes Your Man" or something
that's going to perk things
up a little bit.
So it just depends on whatever
is going on in my head,
I guess.
Sometimes Dave picks one.
He has a couple drum kind
of nervous energy things
he'll do that we know
he's getting ready to do
a certain particular song.
And it'll be like that one.
DAVID: And we cheat sometimes,
because some songs go together.
That goes hand-in-hand.
That'll happen.
Visual signs.
JASON: I like that.
Keeps the audience on your
toes, but it keeps the band
on your toes as well, right?
I read for this
particular tour, you guys
rehearsed around 90 songs
that at any given time
you can just kind of
pull out and play.
Let me direct this
question to you, Paz.
You're the newest
member of the band,
here for about a year and
a half, two years now.
Can you tell us what
that process was
like once you joined the band?
How do you learn 90 songs?
Since you weren't around when
these songs were originally
written in the '80s and
'90s, you pull these out.
Is it a little more difficult
for you to kind of go
through that process, or has
it been fairly simple for you?
You've obviously played
music for a long time.
So what's that
been like for you?
PAZ: I broke my foot and
I couldn't do anything
except for listen and play.
So I was in my room.
This was four years
ago, by the way.
I've been in the
band for four years.
And yeah, I was in
my bedroom listening,
because just to listen
to all of the songs
would take about five
hours just to listen to it.
So imagine oh, I wonder
how the bass part goes.
Then it's another five hours.
So there goes 10 hours.
And so yeah, you have to make
sure you're really listening.
JOEY: I have to apologize, Paz.
I was the one that
broke your foot.
PAZ: Yeah, he was like, no,
you're not going anywhere.
JASON: Is that what kept you?
Yeah, that's what
got you in the band.
They broke your foot
and made you stay.
Is that right?
Paz, for your first kind
of rehearsal with the band,
is it true that your mom dropped
you off at the rehearsal?
Did I hear that correctly?
PAZ: That's true, yeah.
JASON: I love this story.
It's so awesome.
It's so rock and roll.
PAZ: My first rehearsal,
this was before we met up
with Charles in North Hampton.
We were in California
and my car broke down.
And I had all my
notes and things.
I was like, Mom, can you
drop me off at the studio?
She was so excited.
I just knew it would
make her super excited.
She came and picked me
up and dropped me off
at the rehearsal space in L.A.
JASON: That's amazing.
Most of us--
PAZ: And she picked me up too.
And she's like, how did it go?
[LAUGHTER]
JASON: Obviously well.
Most of us get dropped
off at the movie theater
by our parents.
Paz gets dropped off to join
an amazing rock and roll band.
Your story is slightly
better than ours.
David, let me ask you,
on the subject of Paz,
since we're chatting
with her right now.
Again, the newest
member of the band.
Four years, my apologies.
I cut it a little short, so
I didn't mean to do that.
Can you talk a little bit
about the dynamic of the band
and how it's changed
since Paz has joined?
Obviously she fits in well.
I'm watching you
guys play for us
and the dynamic is fantastic.
Can you talk a
little bit about what
that's been like to
have her join the group?
DAVID: Well, it's wonderful.
Well, she's made me play
better, because she's so good,
I don't want to be embarrassed.
I had to step up my game.
But yeah, it's fantastic.
She's a joy to be around.
She plays well.
And like I've always
said, it's funny
because she's been
with us for four years.
She still feels
like the new woman,
so the men are all still
behaving very well.
JASON: On your best behavior.
DAVID: Yes.
JASON: And too, you're the third
female bassist for the band
as well.
It's kind of part of
the DNA of the band,
I suppose, to have a strong
female bassist in there
as well, which is fantastic.
Let's get back to the new--
I call it the new album.
I guess it's still
new, a year old.
The newest album, I
suppose, "Head Carrier"
Charles, maybe for
you, you came out
with an album a few years
ago, which you kind of
considered more, I think I read
in an article, a little bit
more of a transitional
album, where this is kind
of your return to the
Pixies, this newest
album "Head Carrier."
Can you kind of
talk about why you
feel this album is
different than the albums
that you've released
in the past,
or maybe quite similar to some
of the original four albums
that you released?
CHARLES: I guess because
we have a bass player.
In the previous record, we
lost our original bassist
during the session.
Anyway, so we had
a friend of ours
named Ding came to the
session, and he played the bass
for the rest of the session.
So we worked it out, but
it was still a little bit
like, there was this
kind of vacant chair.
We had booked the studio, and
we were with our old producer
friend, and we were there.
We were in this little
village in Wales.
And it was like, well, we
got to make the record,
because we've got these
songs and we got this,
we're in Wales.
We don't want to leave.
We just got here.
So we just did it.
So it came out the
way it came out.
And we got through it.
So yeah, I guess
it was transitional
because we had this sort of,
we were missing a fourth member
for that kind of dynamic.
And so fortunately for
this last session, we did.
We were like a unit.
So we're making the coffee
together, hanging out.
And it was communal
and it was a band.
JASON: It felt good, right.
Yeah, absolutely.
Well, the album is fantastic.
Has the songwriting
process changed at all?
You've got the feeling
of a band again.
You've got a great feel.
You guys have a great chemistry.
Has the process, either
of writing the music
itself, the genesis of
the song or the lyrics,
has that changed at
all for you guys,
or is it still fairly similar?
Does it kind of remain
similar from the '80s
when you first started writing
and producing music to now?
CHARLES: I guess
it feels the same.
I mean, you've got
microphones and tape
recorders and instruments.
You try to do something that
feels interesting or fun
or something to play.
And you just, well, we'll
try this one and see how.
Sometimes it comes back
through the speakers
and it's like, wow, I didn't
know it was that good.
And other times it's sort of
like, uh, it's not so good.
I don't know.
Every song is different.
I think I read an interview
years ago with Beck.
I think he was saying that every
song is like a little country
and it has its own
rules and customs.
And I totally understand that.
So when you start to write a
song, it's like, oh, it's this.
This is the song, even if
it's not fully matriculated.
You know what I mean?
You kind of have a
sense of, oh, that
follows the customs
of the country.
And then other times
you try something
and it's like, that
doesn't fit this country.
They wouldn't do that there.
So it's just kind of, I
don't know, that's how it is.
JASON: And it works, right?
CHARLES: Yeah, I hope so.
JASON: You're still
selling tickets,
so I think it's still working.
Joey, let me ask you, speaking
of composition, so you've
done some really cool work
outside of the band as well,
composing commercials, composing
movie and TV soundtracks,
things like that.
How does that process,
does it differ
from what Charles was
just mentioning, where
it's got a certain feel to it?
Or does that feel completely
different than the type
of music that you're producing
and creating with the Pixies?
JOEY: It get very lonely just
by myself working all the time.
Yeah, of course it
feels different.
It's everyone's project.
It's their pet.
It's the last piece
of the puzzle.
So I'm their slave?
[LAUGHS]
No.
It's a fun process.
It's amazing.
My son, I was doing
a horror movie
and I had him push a button.
Well, a key, like
an ominous sound.
And I go, when he walks
through that door, push it.
And when he exits, take it out.
I gave him $5.
[LAUGHTER]
JASON: That's pretty cool.
And Paz, you helped out
with some of this as well.
If you guys haven't
seen, a quick plug.
Joey and Paz did a really
cool, I think it was Acura,
am I right?
An Acura commercial
maybe a year or two ago.
And I might be
wrong on that too.
But if you guys haven't seen
it, look it up on YouTube.
It's actually one of
the coolest commercials.
So you were able to kind of
work out on that as well,
so expanding outside of the band
as well, which is fantastic.
It's very cool.
What was that
process like for you?
You're classically trained,
I know, as a musician.
Was that kind of fun to be
able to flex that a little bit?
PAZ: That was really fun, yeah.
I played piano and the
violin and I got my sister
to play the cello on there.
Just trying different
arrangements
of "Where's My Mind."
Yeah, it was really fun.
JASON: Yeah.
Well, hopefully we can
pump up some YouTube views
on that commercial.
It's on there.
I watched it recently.
Let me talk a little
bit, so I guess
we're talking about technology.
And we are at Google, which
is a technology company.
So usually when we
have bands in here,
we like to ask a question
around how you guys feel
about the utilization
of technology
with what you guys do, whether
it's connectivity with fans,
whether it's selling tickets,
whether it's social media
and staying in touch
with family members.
And you guys too,
I think you guys
were I guess early quote,
unquote, "pioneers"
in terms of your interaction
with digital media.
You guys released a lot of
music on it was called eMusic.
You guys were very
early to iTunes.
So I feel like,
like it or not, you
guys also embrace some of
the digital movement of music
as well.
So that's all encompassing
technology in general.
But would just kind
of love to hear
how you guys feel about
technology and music,
whether it's been
good or bad and how
that's worked for you guys.
CHARLES: We had a
meeting this morning
on the bus on the way
over here about the songs
we were going to play.
But also we discussed, I
guess we're a little behind.
We told Simon, our
tour manager, that we
wanted one of those
speakers that you just
shout out and tell it
what music to play.
There's Alexa, right?
That's the one my brother has.
JASON: I've never
heard of that one.
[LAUGHTER]
There's one called
Google Home, though.
I've heard it's quite fantastic.
CHARLES: Maybe get a free one.
Maybe.
I don't know.
Google Home.
We don't care, as long as
it plays the damn Chet Baker
record or whatever
we want to listen to.
You know what I mean?
So yeah, we like the tech.
JASON: Any other thoughts
from anyone else?
JOEY: Technology is good.
DAVID: One difference
from then and now
is now there's Jumbo-trons
when you do live shows.
There weren't them in the past.
So now you've got
to like, oh no.
JASON: You can see
yourself performing.
DAVID: Technology in that way.
JASON: What's next?
So you guys are, again,
a year out on the release
of "Head Carrier."
You guys are obviously touring.
I know you have a lot more
stops on this particular tour.
Any writing for the next album?
Any thoughts of
what's coming up next?
I know you have
a big anniversary
coming up next year for
"Surfer Rosa," which
is I believe 20 years old?
Or 30 years old.
CHARLES: We're going to
retake our "Surfer Rosa"
vows at the shows
together as a band.
JASON: A re-commitment.
CHARLES: Yeah.
I gotta start writing
them now [INAUDIBLE]..
JASON: Anniversary tour
for that, as you guys
did with "Doolittle?"
Are you guys going to
work on some new music?
CHARLES: We got a jam session
scheduled tomorrow night.
Tomorrow afternoon.
Well, in Grand Rapids.
We jam out about
three times a week
during the day at
wherever we're playing.
Not every day, but about.
So the last jam we
had was in Cleveland?
No, Toronto.
Anyway, we're overdue
for a little jam
where we play new chord
shapes and that kind of thing.
So yeah, we have begun
working on new songs
and we'll be jamming
them tomorrow.
JASON: I love it.
See what sticks.
I love it.
Fantastic.
I've got one more
question, then we'll
open it up for maybe one
or two audience questions.
If you've got a
question, think of it
and we'll get you a mic
here in just a second.
This is what I consider
a fun question,
and it's for each of you.
So we'll go down the row.
So a lot of times when
somebody is new to Google,
we will ask them what their
guilty pleasure music is.
Essentially what I mean by that
is, if I pulled up next to you
and you were sitting
at a stoplight
and your window was down and
you were just jamming out
to a particular song
or musician but maybe
were a little embarrassed that
that's who you're listening to,
who would that be?
Maybe like Justin
Bieber, Britney Spears,
something like that.
Anything that you guys have?
JOEY: Leo Sayer, "You Make
Me Feel Like Dancing."
JASON: Singing along?
You sing along to it?
Top of the lungs?
JOEY: It just makes me happy.
JASON: Yeah?
I love it.
Charles, you got on?
CHARLES: I don't know if I
have a funny one or anything.
JASON: It doesn't
have to be funny.
CHARLES: I don't
have a Leo Sayer.
Lately I've been
listening to this guy.
Hector Lavoe.
He's a Puerto
Rican salsa singer.
He's passed away now, but
he made a lot of records
with Willie Colon, who
was a New York trombone.
They'd make these, in the
'60s, early '70s, records.
But that's what I've
been when I want peppy.
JASON: I love it.
David?
DAVID: Well, it's tough.
I don't think it's, what do
you call it, a guilty pleasure,
but Steely Dan and Rush.
JASON: Classics.
Those are inspirations
too, right?
That's fantastic.
Paz, what about you?
PAZ: I guess I
would be embarrassed
to my interpretation
of Edith Piaf,
pretending that I
know what I'm singing.
JASON: Just making noise that
sounds good along to the music.
PAZ: That sounds French.
Kind of French-like.
JASON: I was really
hoping that one of you
would say you listen to
the Pixies in the car
while you guys are driving.
PAZ: I definitely
have done that.
I definitely have done that.
JASON: Just jamming
out to your own music.
I would just die if I
pulled up next to one of you
and you were singing
your own music.
I've always dreamt of that.
PAZ: I don't know,
a good way to see
how your record sounds
is putting it in your car
and going for a drive.
If it drives well,
it sounds good.
JASON: I love it.
That's what we listen to
most of our music too.
Very cool.
JOEY: I feel like I opened up
my soul with saying Leo Sayer.
JASON: You led off strong.
I like that.
It's out there now.
It's going to be
on the internet.
You can't take it back.
CHARLES: No way.
[APPLAUSE]
It's all about the
perks, Simon, the perks.
Look at that.
JOEY: Three more, please.
CHARLES: Leo Sayer, before
we go on, Joe, tonight.
Going to get happy.
JOEY: I wouldn't mind my own.
JASON: I like that.
CHARLES: Thank you very much.
JASON: Thank you, guys.
Any questions from the audience?
Anyone want to
shout one out here?
AUDIENCE: I guess I'd
direct this towards Charles,
going back in the
beginning days.
What was the transition,
in other words,
from playing music,
doing covers, and making
that transition going
to original music?
Could you tell us a little
bit about how that happened
versus slugging it
out in the nightclubs?
CHARLES: Well, we
played in nightclubs,
but we were playing in, I
don't know what you call it,
a musical culture where you
didn't really do cover songs.
If you do cover songs, you play
at a certain kind of a club.
But the kind of clubs
that we were playing at,
that would have
been frowned upon.
You wouldn't have been
even allowed a slot.
It doesn't matter what
kind of a racket you make,
it has to be your
racket or whatever.
So we've learned over the
years a couple of songs,
but I personally find
it very challenging
to learn other people's music,
even if it's a simple song,
because it's confusing to me.
I don't know.
So we don't do a lot of covers.
We never did when we
were starting out.
But that's just
because we were playing
in Boston and those
clubs there, it
wasn't about
playing cover music.
So I'm glad I didn't have to.
Some people, they
might live in the town
where that might be
the transition that you
have to kind of go
through to, I don't know,
get to that next stop.
But we didn't have to do that.
I don't know what we
would have played.
Trying to think.
I don't know.
Probably like--
JASON: Steely Dan?
CHARLES: The Cars,
probably, or something.
JASON: Any other questions
from the audience?
Sure.
AUDIENCE: Any one of you
guys can answer this.
I was wondering if there's
any bands that you guys would
like to play with
that you haven't had
the chance to play with yet?
Like go on tour,
maybe, or something.
DAVID: Steely Dan and Rush.
[LAUGHTER]
CHARLES: That would be good.
JOEY: Leo.
And oh my god.
That would blow a lid on people.
JASON: I love it.
CHARLES: Edith Piaf.
JASON: Themes going on.
PAZ: She's dead.
CHARLES: Some years ago we
played a few shows with Weezer.
And there's something
about that band
that they're kind of more
pop-oriented than we are,
but there's some kind of
aesthetic that they have
which I think that all of
us in the band, we like it
or whatever.
JOEY: That would
be an amazing tour.
JASON: I would buy a
ticket for that show.
Weezer and the Pixies.
See if we can make that happen.
That would be fantastic.
AUDIENCE: I have a
question and somewhat also
an embarrassing story.
But I'll start with
the question first.
Hopefully well run out of time
before the embarrassing story.
I feel like with musicians
they have a unique relationship
with music itself.
So there's sort of like a
relationship with a person.
There's love, sometimes
it's difficult,
it can be hard
writing and performing
and things like that.
Have you ever had a
moment in your career
when you've maybe fallen
out of love with music
or writing it or doing
it, performing, even
listening to it?
And if that has happened,
what's the one thing
that sort of brought you back?
Whether it was like,
maybe you had a child
or maybe, I don't know,
you just listened to a band
and it just sort of brought
you back into things?
JASON: As you can see, we
like multi-part questions
here at Google.
It's hard to follow
along sometimes.
But I think we got that one.
Thanks, Eric.
DAVID: Well, I can say when the
band, when we dissolved a while
back, I kind of gave up drums.
This was great,
playing with this.
And I did some
session work, nah.
Gave up drums.
Didn't think about it for,
I don't know, 10 years.
But then when we
got back together,
it was like, whoa,
what have I done?
It's was like a lost love.
JASON: And for those
of you that don't know,
David also became a professional
musician during that time.
PAZ: Magician.
JASON: Magician.
DAVID: It's only a couple of
letters off my business card
if I change.
JASON: Magician.
So if you haven't, another
YouTube task for you
afterwards is to look
up some of his shows.
They're fantastic.
CHARLES: One of
my kids, she likes
kind of macho dude singers.
You know what I mean?
I figured that out when
she was pretty young.
That's what she kind
of resonates with.
So I'm always like, you got
to check out Three Dog Night.
And then she'll then be Three
Dog Night for about a month.
And then, you gotta
check out Cat Stevens.
So it's kind of like I get
to relive a lot of records
I listened to when I was a kid.
When you have kids, you kind
of go, hey, [INAUDIBLE]..
Unless they're kind
of like, you know,
if they're that age
where they don't
want to have anything to do
with you, then you can't really.
But she's in this sweet spot
right now where it's like,
hey, I got a suggestion
for you, and then
she'll just totally
take it and run.
So that's been nice to listen
to a lot of records that way
that I haven't listened
to in a long time.
AUDIENCE: How long did
you wait before you let
her put a needle on a record?
At what age?
CHARLES: Oh, I don't know.
We're not real, I don't know.
We've got a lot of broken
stuff in our house.
We're not really that precious
about that kind of stuff.
JASON: Cool.
Maybe one more question?
Leah?
AUDIENCE: So your
lyrics, I know you
said you just put
together what sounds good
when you write your songs.
But are there ever a
deeper meaning behind some
of the lyrics you write?
Because they don't
always make sense to me.
[LAUGHTER]
CHARLES: Yeah.
Sorry, sometimes there is.
And sometimes there is
when you're doing it,
when you're kind of writing.
It's kind of
internalized process.
It's kind of mental
and you're kind
of jumping all over the place
and you're kind of, oh yeah,
the dots are all connecting
now, they're all connecting now.
And then it's over and
then a year later it's
like, I don't even
know what it's about.
I can't recreate whatever
was going on in my head
at that time.
So it's just like, yeah, it
just kind of sounds the way--
They're not all like that,
but that's how it is for me.
JASON: That's amazing.
Thank you guys.
Guys, one more time,
let's give a round
of applause for that Pixies.
Thank you so much,
guys, for coming in.
Really appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]